Emily you're directing this season
premiere right I am I've just are you
excited about that I really am I've had
a really wonderful time prepping I did
week and a half of prep which is
wonderful to do while not shooting
another episode that's what happens when
you do the premiere um and then so I get
to direct all these guys uh starting
Monday
I work Tuesday now have you been I know
I'm not working Monday I'll be warming
up with everyone else well I'm working
Tuesday I'm not I'm not working Monday
and leaning on David okay conflict
number one I'm not coming in Monday yes
well we do David get around a bunch of
these shows so what I texted him to talk
and then we haven't spend the time to
talk because I've been so crazy
prepping but yes I'm definitely picking
his brain and I've been studying his
episode the last episode because it's
kind of a continuation the season
premiere is a continuation of the
episode that people saw maybe 20 minutes
of last night um who directed that one
David I did diven Thank You episode
thank you so much God a great job thank
you so much for having us
how beautiful is Emily and it's this
beautiful cast know people down here
look at John he just he's less first sub
Michael the other job didn't you know
you look great man look at you sure came
right out it what your kids are in the
show right my kids know one of yours one
of yours oh yeah yeah our kids were on
the show remember that's right Bella's
waves she said something why are they
all anthropologists or something that
was just just the start just starting
something to now him nice
you don't want she ride towards she's a
horseback rider mmm you know you're not
saying anything
well yes he was on the show but I wasn't
gonna tell people he was on the ship
okay it was just a fun thing to have do
but he hated it um and he's not going to
be returning nor would I want him to be
an actor but yeah okay now TJ and
Michaela you've spent Jack you've been
in a wheelchair yeah
god bless you know I got I heard my name
I got excited I was like oh my turn
did your characters have gone through a
lot of strain this year are you gonna
make it are you gonna pull through
yeah I think Jack and Angela will always
make it I think they'll be okay yeah
Makayla tell us about the love you feel
for this man tell you about the love I
feel like this man I so much love we've
done so many scenes and seasons with
these people it's really just it's so
many emotions at one time to think about
the show ending I can't even really talk
about it properly obviously this being a
list rated right now but it's really I
mean it's in terms of our storyline I
think we had a really great time with it
but I'm also really glad that we have
the opportunity to honor this show with
a proper ending after all the episodes
that we've done it's really that's
really special Tamara there's a there's
a phrase Camus dude that's going around
yeah I know it doesn't really what can
we expect and this Camus to phrase it's
a good filmmaker very awkward is there
gonna be a little bundle of joy there's
something it's more gonna hurt more
gonna happen here yeah well yeah you
know I kind of thought that the the
writers were maybe gonna cheat me out of
a wedding and it sounds like they're not
I think cam and Aris who are doing oh
yeah yeah and John the relationship that
you have going on the show what's gonna
happen here do you have any inside info
on what you think it's gonna happen I
want to take a redhead out to eat I
think is all I need why did you care to
eat so much John hmm uh John it's
Michael just peel back the layers that
only the showrunners can tell us yours
and another undercover episode for Booth
and Brennan its season 12 what do you
think best one ever
um great undercover episode is a world
we've never been in that um I think only
booth and Brendan can do justice to and
I'm not going to tell anything more
about it
what okay then we wearing great shirts
baby suspenders hmm I can't understand
what you're seeking here anybody on the
end what do you say
Lumberjacks you're gonna be a lumberjack
to said so now you say take a train what
you're taking for Jack Lumberjacks I'm
gonna be a lumberjack yeah what do I get
to be a lumberjack to what am i making
maple syrup what is that all that's
usable um Burton syrup where are you
gonna be hey we'll move on on up there
what are you wait I'm a lumberjack and
bones is what a lumberjack are you mean
like a tree cutter it's gonna be great
you're a lot cutting trees
you're gonna wrestle a bear I'm gonna
rest the bear tandem saw tandem saw and
saw about the role you're rolling and
you can't fall off in the water and
you're going back and forth you know you
can do that really well I could at the
point
wait yak on the water nice fall
immediately no I'd save you a lot of
these things okay well I won't save you
I'll let you drown why are we just doing
the ocean with a great white and Cape
Town and see what happens you're more
likely to be struck by lightning than to
be bitten by a shark who says that
science okay let's go tell you what I
see
okay let's go let's go to the water get
some Chum throw it out in the water and
see if the lightning comes see if the
shark comes I guarantee you the goddamn
sharks gonna come before the lightning
I'm just saying it's just what Erica T
on the show what you see on the show
this is it I mean this is a chemistry
look it's just happening right in front
of you isn't it amazing can we take
these home on people isn't it amazing
it's like a lightsaber thing here it's a
naked do all right season 12 the last
season of the show anyway that let's
just go down the line here how do you
see your how do you see it ending for
your characters hmm hopefully not in
death oh well I'll go with that I'll
leave that to the writers to figure out
I mean I hope that there's some kind of
happy ending on some level even though I
know that there's going to be some
sadness in the end the season but I
would love to see Brennan grow even more
but there's still that that still core
person that she's always been intact um
yeah but I leave it to the writers to
really figure that out that's not for me
to do I think God this is the part where
I get really emotional
now all seriousness um are you gonna cry
are you gonna take any props with you
when you go I'm dictating everything
let's be honest I'm gonna be wiped out
I'm gonna sell it on eBay I'm gonna sell
it and gear up I'm gonna do a couple
signings I'm back
are there spares of that of the the
famous belt buckle know that well
there's a lot of to that and I think
that maybe we could we should have a
conversation about that do you want to
do it now bring the con on there better
okay here's what I'm thinking all right
we're in the middle of the ocean okay
and there's a shark now and my belt
buckle like all settings like I'm
lightning strikes and I'm on the log
rolling around throwing Chum okay
someone of a pencil John is making subs
or eating like crab dip for some reason
a TJ he's at the top of the helm with
Michaela and they're doomed we're
reliving - Titanic or something like
that a scene okay tomorrow and Paige
they're like I don't know they're
they're like looking at maps we're right
and all of a sudden I I get hit by
lightning and in my trusty belt buckle
is a raft whoa okay and this and the
boat sinks and now I have to put
everybody in the raft in the cocky raft
yes yeah and we just kind of like float
off into the sunset and there's route
there's a lot of Sun and then you're
telling me about sunscreen and I'm
arguing about that maybe you and Paige
you're I don't know doing something in
the back of the boat but we need their
map oh we need the map some math and we
need boom so we have like teen subs with
us and Jane Mikayla are still doing the
Titanic scene are the Lumberjacks in
this episode yes I think it's a great
way so that's my idea for the belt
buckle all right
that's a marine line Everett and well
worked out ideas thank you
we might have it something else in mind
but this is obviously better John and
Michael are any of the recurring
characters going to die in season 12 me
a little bit maybe huh I need a railing
good way no one at this table will say
that but there are two other people from
past up to who will die in this Apollo
season so yes they're laughing when they
say that you know gotten sick sorry
maybe I get it with a chainsaw and I'm
dead
they're gonna die wax what about four
four seven are we ever gonna find out
please oh yeah what is yes episode 11 of
next season you will find out what four
four seven means okay 7:00 p.m. it's
time for every horrible is re-written
and Zack what's going to happen with
Zack you asked that we brought them back
and yeah I think that's been the most
fun is you know before being on the show
writing on the show I was a fan of the
show and I loved everything that he
brought and its delight to bring him
back and but the story is not over yet
we're going to try to bring him back for
three to four more episodes so there is
an arc and a story left to be told so
don't assume anything
you